all right to all the people who are
saying thanks for the stream I'm back
with another stream of playing the hyper
bullet shield arena oh let me join the
term that before it starts I'm number
two seed oh man
I'm playing decent high rated player
hopefully there's no lag mentally
prepare myself let's play Cambridge
Springs ooh that was bad that was really
bad okay at least I have an F file the
knight on that for no I didn't want to
do that okay
scary let's defend this is really
terrifying
what's wrong with the King I the last
stream was so hopefully instructive this
one's just going to be a complete mess
what do I do
let's take the pawn
I have to dirty flag the sky no he's
made it me it's unfortunate okay I feel
like I'm gonna lose a lot of points of
stream but I'll try and play decently
let's play London London will probably
be my go-to opening so solid
yeah this is nice oh this is very nice
have some attack I'm gonna play King H 1
row G 1 and G 4 maybe there we go it's
open the G file the rook on g4 and bring
the other rook to G 1 mmm I guess I have
to trade Queens I'll still have some
attack though free pawn g7 is now a
target third what kind of g3 ooh free
Bishop so nice ok I want a game ok yeah
this is gonna be a tricky stream cuz
it's gonna be hard to interact with the
chat and play chess but I'll try and
hello to people
hello pro-amateur James and callek Skye
have an desk wigs
thanks for the sub it's this guy you're
gonna flag hey free tournament points no
free rating points but I'm top 2001 D
Pro former winner of the me chest title
marina okay let's play the Budapest
Budapest is great cuz usually whites
allows taking on d4 hey it's more pits
from more bits from cars my little heart
lies in noodle
thanks for the bits 2,000 bits I'm gonna
play a four eight I can't talk it's so
hard to do things
let's just not flag
Chuck very sneaky Chuck
yeah talking and playing 30-second chess
is not a good combination
I just want to meet him I could move
let's play that by five
mmm
hey I won with a second left I do
appreciate the bits how do I pronounce
your name heart wise a noodle or is it
Weiser noodle or is it Nuttall okay new
game if you can like say the phonetic
pronunciation that would be nice we move
Knight f3 okay tricky tricky still go
for a London set up without my D pawn
its
win a pawn the ship g3 looks solid I'm
gonna go for a sneaky mates Queen d3 and
winning h7 that didn't work
now other plan is to get the Knights
oops I plunder tonight there goes a plan
maybe f5 this looks nice attack the
Queen
and so long on time though so slow
please wonder mate not gonna blunder it
ooh he blundered it
it's so nice low on time I was down at
peace okay I've three wins top ten so
decently high rated players here but
deep pro is almost twenty nine hundred
ways a noodle okay it's pronounced like
oh maybe it's pronounced like an a huh
okay new game let's play a d4 I don't
know why I was so slow the previous game
playing the slime Queen b3 k e4 is a
main plan oh that's a free Bishop
because my rooks not trapped it's nice
of him
maybe I could drop the Queen but maybe
not
I'm gonna go for a Sun King side attack
I feel like he's lacking defenders
I just plunder a piece I blunder the
piece maybe I can drop the Queen Queen
is so slippery
when I get my team to c3 there we go
they work on me to some ice block aid
slightly dirty there I'll take it all
right
Vova chess trying to think I know what
opening he plays okay we'll play like
Carlson now to defend the pawn that was
nice of him let's take take do this 94
mm-hmm ha that's nice but not at v6 that
I'll go for let go for some eventual
mate like this
save the night I'm gonna bring the
Knight to g4 time is good - this is
hanging good [ __ ] there maybe
what's going on
you just want to flag them
hey flagged okay those are really dirty
finish I just blundered everything but I
was faster top three top four I haven't
lost a game since the first round let's
play another London it's kind of working
well let's play g4 this is a nice
variation G pawn for econ with the pawn
on c4 avoid any Queen trade what
thinking on e two should be safe there
c5 and then a 3 B 4 is coming and then
f3 to play h4 and Bishop g5 move free
Queen take the bishop first the Knights
kind of trapped let me open the a file
maybe e4 I just want to open the center
play e5 of the Queen to h6 the rook here
kind of trait with my rook not a bad
move by him it should be made somehow
it's not me yet
there we go it's not to tell me the
affair because he has a beep lon
all right it's penguin coming think was
not here yet so playing Vova chess again
[Music]
let's play this line and just trade
everything meant to play Knight of three
but that's okay trade more stuff Castle
now we have a very positional game I'll
defend the b-pawn but the knight and d4
no I want to triple up
and win the pong it's Peggy for
ooh tricky the Queen on e3 I guess I'm
slightly faster more free Brooke that's
nice
the ponzu they'll under the rook I'm
moving quickly I'm just going to push
the pawn
that's a race like wing with check
that's nice Nate okay top three I was a
little bit nerve-racking like 1800 this
is nice let's take their do you five
free pawn I'm sucking it back just a
complete development maybe I'll hang
that great mates I have the bishop here
to double up the rooks I didn't want to
do that
that's okay so we're trading everything
I'll have an active rook maybe put the
Rick here do this yeah
rook is much more active keep rooks on
the board
activate the King pawn d5 before
no I blended it rook mmm please don't
pretty move stuff flag flag flag flag
flag yes okay gaining points Oh penguin
has has a shield and he's catching up
that's terrifying
he's 28:51 I'm sandwiched between two
2,850 Plus players good thing I'm
playing someone lower rated it's from
coward Khan
oh I'm white I move first okay I'll play
this line h4 h5 let's play that defend
to stay with F pawn 92 okay very close
position now it's about to just become
wide open maybe I'll hang repeats its
attack of rook a4 maybe mm-hmm let's do
this
I broke up seven there we go oh no I
didn't want to do that no obvious I have
a fork I'm gonna save my night cuz it's
tricky it's some weird compensation
maybe he'll get needed he's getting
mated what a mate's Wow rook on f7 so
clutch for me I was a save like no other
okay the regos mmm let's play this qgd
semi Slav Bishop f4 okay who free bishop
good try cuz he not slipped let's take
this and take this in Castle Knight d5
me six I wanted to play Queen d6 but
it's okay
save the bishop kind of annoying
position I have some time c6 no you
didn't take my rook though I'd blundered
a queen no just start pre moving like at
the knight to h4 ah this is really bad
move free Queen this is really good
Friedrich this is really good I have
plenty of time
this is not real chess I saw I'm sorry
to the people who are watching who want
real chess I'm on the streak third place
so the lag isn't too bad there's a
little bit of lag but it's still good
enough oh I'm playing the penguin okay
so we have a budapest he's playing this
line good line
I have some time advantage but he's so
fast later in the game to be very
careful let's play this and this and
this and trade bishops he doesn't want
to trade I'm gonna play c5 and some at
my Knights maybe a rookie a queen e8
tack the e pawn okay
attacking stuff hey listen Knight g4
also a way up on time
this is getting terrifying though
defending
God blundered
No
[Music]
I'm so slow okay was a close game though
top five still but he's gonna win it
like guaranteed he's so good
okay now I'm playing someone who I
should be able to beat or at least flag
let's play listen this yeah this is a
nice line Queen you for coming very fun
variation
I have everything developed and black
has nothing developed oh I've got kind
of got for it is it okay it's not okay
there was some compensation maybe even
he six he's playing accurately he's
playing a little bit slowly
oh that's meat Wow 97 was the worst
possible move the position okay I'll
take that
try and stay like in the top five
let's play before I blunder to be pawn
that's okay can treat this as a gambit
try and win the H pawn let's do this
threatening meets to be a little bit
careful do this
it's very scary position I want to have
the Queen meeting the battery g5 I just
want to meet on each to threatening mate
he saw it
Wow
just resigns because this is coming nice
44 points so my only losses have been
two really good players and I'm about to
break 2600 I usually play much worse on
on stream at least in fast chess okay
try and be in the zone I was not
expecting that
okay reasonable position three Knights
that's nice of him it's taken win the
pawn
wait I'm up oh no I'm not about any
material I thought I was up material it
sure will happen there
should I get her activated somehow
winning the C pawn and maybe the a pawn
to push the C pawn pushing it doesn't
work now I got a thumb
like yes okay baby onion hello welcome
to the stream okay okay ooh tricky very
tricky
this is playable kind of I don't know
what is this what's going on d5 maybe
coming that five is loose win the bishop
back and have this move
I'm playing much faster than him which
is good check the night oh no that's not
good this is not good
wait let's take that what is this
endgame
it's a pawn race my mouse is slipping
yeah I flagged him okay
my mouse pad is a literally a chess
board people can see
oh no what did I break oh just
air-conditioned I'm remote
well I'm playing penguin again okay
let's play and default let's play London
he always pre moves he takes e5 yeah
oh he's gonna play that oh i blundered a
bishop what it's so bad so me some
slightly more developed was queen d8
let's play c4
try and get the G file pressure
he's gonna win this nine seconds doesn't
seem like a lot of time but that's like
90 moves for penguin
please still me me please please no he's
so fast like both games I've been on the
verge of flagging him but maybe it's no
illusion okay
hey I'm 2600 on the dot don't really
lose points for losing Tim oh this is
such a fun line such a fun line he's
actually playing decently like I might
not have any advantage anymore but it's
still fun let's do this and I'll sack
the night and get the rook just some
file always play King bee one my meeting
where's the mates
I wouldn't let Bishop and I'm attacking
the rook and I have this move rook h6 is
almost mates
where's inmates oh no I'm getting mated
oh no where was a mate
maybe Bishop takes I had bishop takes
off five Queen takes g5 and I win the
Queen oh that was unfortunate
penguin hasn't lost a single game it's
insane
I still top five lost a lot of rating
points there though okay bullet experts
I'm allowing before that heat into bits
okay
that's playable in trade Queens put the
night here but the rooks in the game go
for the trade put the bishop on d4 maybe
try them in this pawn take first cool I
went up on and c3 coming his bishops
really stuck almost dropping the rook
there this is just winning I think
almost gonna take and do this and now
it's winning right now it's completely
winning
have enough time good try
okay muck deep wrote paused so maybe
I'll pass them at some points playing
though the chess again but decent score
against so far
but the knight on e5 just get the bishop
here I'm gonna put my bishop on g6 play
c6 he wants to meet me on the diagonal I
want to meet him on the diagonal to
let's play this tack just trying to be
solid oops I hung a queen that's not the
most solid move I could do still feel
somewhat solid just down a queen oh I
could have taken this Queen accidentally
was dirty there ah he meets me ah
it's unfortunate ax can't axe thanks for
the comment
Norwegian Giants hello okay let's try
and change the momentum my H 4 is
usually a nice move good the bishop pair
I'll leave the tension between the
Queen's is it's usually useful for me if
he takes g4 maybe g4 g5 I have the
bishop pair I have nice structure for
this you should a six coming threatening
to trap the rook let's just fork the
rooks and make them confused
okay ooh ooh I should play f4 first
when the pond go after East six maybe
okay quick enough
fourth place catching up to my tee pro
switch I want to try and break 2600
again okay we have some opening now some
middle game I'll put the knight on e4
get the bishop hair and win upon light
scores are weak in White's camp I'm
gonna hold on to the night maybe push
the H pawn am I losing a piece it's kind
of annoying that's I'm down on time too
maybe I couldn't win each three there we
go the Queen to five avoid the Queen
trade at all costs when the e3 pawn went
to c3 pawn we can see two will be mates
that was nice yeah penguins strong this
guy is also strong good try almost got
me
let's activate the Queen me h4 h5
know what's going on ooh Nathan - now I
know what's going on okay some nice
mates a couple last couple of games
approaching 2600 again everyone playing
this line its trade Queens or not
queen sharain yeah so i'm up upon decent
position night of three allows the night
to get trapped the e4 e5 but the night
on d6 and c4
he takes my night i take his night I get
a pawn to d6 this is nice epic pawn
chain keep pushing pawns at some points
I didn't mean to do that let's take this
pawn first trade and win the night
birthplace still oh mighty Pro is
playing again five points away from 2600
mmm okay
we need revenge when opening am I gonna
play okay so we're gonna have this
budapest lining in d5 and this is a true
gambit now do this let's take castle
oh he mated me oh I was moving too
quickly they're easy to move too quickly
in 30 second chess Center for trick
a ship g4 after night h3 okay grab the
material let's go for Bishop g4 anyway
looking nice yeah Bishop f7 keeps things
safe
looky ADA's come in the Queen
yeah this is just a king hunt as nice
hey it's a sub J Jase Jase the rat or
Jase a threat
thanks for the sub okay we have some
opening
you choose fine it's okay get the bishop
way Knight f5 more aggressive have to be
aggressive when you're down material to
avoid the Queen trade each file opening
would be very nice yes ooh scary
g4
okay it's turned in my favor
almost broke 2602 points away still in
the fourth place now I'm catching up to
Vova chess who's paused I don't know if
I'm it will play all four hours but
we'll see so I'm playing a semi Slav i
blundered this again
unacceptable may this she looks
reasonable pretty moving a lot
[Music]
let's take there that may have been a
terrible decision what's going on losing
a piece I'm just down a piece but I'm up
a ton of time
let's take this
you just still made me uh-uh I give up
oh I was faster I was having some time
advantage but I just gave away too much
material Navy Nico hello okay so I'm
still in fourth place
this guy's catching up lost some reading
points they're not going to be easy to
break 2600 I'm gonna try free bishop wow
i blundered back why did I do that
it's take maybe I'll play this still up
some material three nights that's nice
I'm sold all in time it's attack
I know I don't know what to do Oh No
okay free pawn nice
okay very dirty flag I'm sure we both
missed many free things I can't find
this guy again let's not play Budapest
playing Enzo or qgd yeah we'll play this
line
hey it's bits a tunafish
thanks for the bits
and she liked my position very
positional g-- file pressure winning
upon maybe double attacking those ponds
losing a piece but maybe promoting
no he's meeting me no oh my position was
nice but I'm just too weak and too slow
and I'm out of teeth still in fourth
place
London is serving me well for the most
parts every game I play penguin I'm
black seems like no except one of them
okay
comfortable position just trade be very
solid
let's trade queens baby or not
Oh No
I flagged no I was not supposed to lose
that few games ago I was like on the
verge of breaking 2600 now I'm 25 51
okay I've meet I need to move faster
only solution okay some interesting
opening kind of Budapest like without
the pawn on c4
I blunder the queen but you didn't see
it this looks reasonable free pawn how
the attack is coming oh no this is
really bad
this is a really bad let's run like the
wind and he has five seconds
oh I offered it draw oops
okay I'm back in the turn uh his attack
was strong losing so many rating points
now I'm playing one of the strongest
players in the tournament let's play
this line one you just plundered a pawn
maybe not
wow this is really bad to play rookie
for I guess this is so bad
too strong way too strong in 5th place
now the goal is to stay above 2500 hmm
what is this
I take c6
okay
this should be a win it's easy position
to play blunder the pawn but that's okay
c2 Falls ah okay weird
no I blunder the Queen okay he blundered
back
I was insane pre-move heaven I don't
know what just happened there i all
night cream was worked somehow so I
worked okay let's do this in the past
maybe I should start pre moving more
figure out how good I am at pre moving
hey it's bits 55 bits thanks ah forgot
about that
please hang mate he saw it
okay I have powerful rooks
let's push pawns a lot a pawn is so hard
to stop I need a miracle
Michael where are you no oh he was low
rated - I don't know how long I'm gonna
do this for try and make another streak
or something this is really draining
yeah
I'm blundering all over the place
and my opponents are just quicker than
me I don't know what happened what a
move you can take on e - no
never resign when you have a night this
is looking very grim though hold on to
my night
there goes my night
oh my god oh he still needed me what I
was about to say I got the Queen but he
was about to meet me that's still need
Wow oh okay some good luck charm sixth
place try and break a hundred
that's why e4 mix it up a little bit
like some Vienna gambit looks like a
reasonable position Queen h5 it's gonna
be aggressive get their work into play
the Queen was kind of trapped there
I'm losing a piece okay I didn't really
work out the way I wanted it to get the
bishop somewhere better
it's gonna take a draw I don't want to
draw though
let's play this yeah he's he should be
flagging
as long as he's not tangling his
flagging
oh don't make me okay my king can run in
his crib
Oh No okay that's good I was find that
Wow
Brooke v8 was a nice gift
okay some opening mmm sacking a pawn I
have some compensation maybe maybe not
the d5 square knock a for win a for the
night in to c3 the bishop on e4 maybe
can take that I think I don't have f6
now I'm turning f6 no I didn't want to
do that a my hyung mates but you need to
see it moving
movie Queen those merciful
I got a Zygon somehow
okay finally
oh that's crazy I have a streak I
haven't had a streak in a long time
two wins in a row I have one game
my opponents stalemated me huh helped
out this guy's playing oh this guy's
playing Knight f3 let's play this
mmm-hmm Queens attacked twice Knight c2
is guaranteed if when a 4 B 5 maybe what
is going on I don't know what's going on
c6 I guess what just happened no idea
what this is oh there goes my night so
proud of that night to to take
so slow I'm not gonna be zerk deserting
is to too much 25:10 and I'm playing
penguin okay we need a c4 we get really
curious while he plays here French okay
play - nice attack this is calm ski a
Kobe in US Championships 2012 maybe
Bishop here and then White's winning but
it's 30 second chess I don't know what's
gonna happen but this is amazing
position for whites there's lighting
such nice opening preparation I better
win this the better ones I'm finding me
that one
how does he defend that's a good sign if
I don't win this I'm quitting the
tournament because this is completely
completely winning okay now it kind of
messed it up it's still winning
No
no such great opening preparation no I
guess I'm quitting the tournament now
what did I say cops kill Kobe in 2012
maybe in 2011
I'm done with the others not not 2012
was their game French Rubinstein this is
taking an unexpectedly instructive turn
2009 2009
wait
oh wait that's the wrong tab there's a
tab
well maybe I got confused oh no here's a
game yeah I remember watching this maybe
I watched it live all right well I saw
it like right afterwards and I was such
great opening preparation from calm ski
because my t5 gets a Bishop parent but
doesn't care about the bishop hair paste
in the game oh I guess it opens in a new
tab
yeah because he combines Bishop b5 and
Queen h5 and then okay my position was
even better if it should be 5 kini 7 oh
so good dyma sunny easy mates I mean
okay I'm just Oliver Queen I can do
anything here can take on f6 I should
just take on at six
yeah taking on e6 is probably just bad I
should still be winning my time
situation was so good too
okay I think I'm gonna end it there
because this is bad this is probably bad
for my health playing so much 30-second
chess it's bad for my wrists probably
not good for the people watching either
but hopefully that was entertaining at
some points I don't know I'll be back in
the future hopefully actually tomorrow
so stay tuned